christian sont offerts une île perdue où
vous allez voir c'est non mais c'est
rien du tout en fait c'est la bonne
invité parce que c'est toujours la bonne
invités je ne suis pas tellement gay on
a lu cette semaine vous faire vous
arrivez avec le sourire déjà on a lu
cette semaine le l'article du parisien
on a en vous entendu sur rtl vous
entendu sur europe et donc on a eu envie
de vous avoir est de vous poser toutes
les questions qui se posent à votre
sujet voilà alors tout à l'heure en vous
présentant moi j'ai dit christine
deviers-joncour mon camarade ruquier qui
n'en rate pas une a dit la [ __ ] de la
république ce qu'il faut dire quand même
c'est que c'est le titre de mon livre
c'est le titre du livre enfin c'est un
cetain un surnom qui vous a été donné
c'est pas vous qui voulez oui j'entends
beaucoup de gens dire que je me suis
baptisée comme ça en fait non je crois
que si on lit la quatrième de couverture
on comprend vite gré que si je ne suis
pas baptisé comme ça j'ai écrit ce livre
pour montrer que je ne suis pas là
ordonne la république on m'a baptisé
comme ça et gelé après en sortant de la
cij a fait parce que les trois avaient
accepté que le livre porte ce titre
aussi mais parce que je crois que j'ai
tous les courages c'est que je crois que
je voulais justement montré que c'était
tellement trop comme ça qu'à travers ce
que j'ai écrit je voulais prouver que
j'étais pas cette femme voilà alors
roland dumas vous appeler ma petite mata
hari on peut aussi vous appelez la mata
hari du périgord ticket ouais mais c'est
plus sympa la mata hari moi je trouve ça
m'a fait drôle parce qu'au départ tiré
ardisson m'a dit tiens tu le faut
absolument que tu lises le bouquin de
dumas j'ai cru que c'était des trois
mousquetaires
et en fait c'était le comte de monte
cristi l'intérieur année
[Applaudissements]
alors votre histoire ça peut aussi
s'appeler trois hommes et une femme
parce que quand on regarde un peu votre
à votre vie finalement comme quand on
lit ce bouquin donc la [ __ ] de la
république chez calmann lévy on pourrait
effectivement appelé c'est à trois
hommes trois hommes et une femme
si cela n'est pas peu dire sans être
vous n'êtes pas eu de chance avec les
mac quoi eux
non mais c'est vrai vous avez comment
vous êtes fille unique de deux
instituteurs à 10h je raconte votre vie
comme ça vous m'arrêtez mais je veux pas
être londres à 17 ans vous préparer le
baccalauréat au lycée la boétie à sarlat
et puis dans la même ville il ya un
garçon qui s'appelle jean jacques de
peretti qui depuis a fait une très belle
carrière et qui était ministre de
monsieur juppé et lui ses parents sont
au maroc ils l'ont envoyée à sarlat il
est très ambitieux il vous dit un jour
je serai maire de sarlat il ce qui est
arrivé est adoré là de quoi elle est
très belle
voilà il monte cyrano et c'est hélas
drame alors maintenant je sais que ça
pour les jeunes d'aujourd'hui ça paraît
absolument incroyable enfin on a le même
âge donc tout on a connu cette époque
c'est vrai que quand une fille se
retrouver enceinte
donc c'était très difficile voilà et
donc vous êtes retrouvée enceinte
oui mais je le regrette pas aujourd'hui
j'ai un fils né en minute frédéric qui
est très très beau absolument et donc
bah voilà vous êtes mariés vous vous
êtes mariés alors que peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui les moeurs ayant évolué
vous seriez fait avorter
donc oui bah tant mieux finalement danse
/ avis d'avoir eu sept enfants
voilà donc mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
il était hors de question de très
difficile
c'était la galère à l'époque c'étaient
des aiguilles à tricoter sur les tables
de cuisine absolument oui c'est moins
une fois que simone veil dont on parlait
tout à l'heure a justement fait voilà
alors donc vous vous mariez avec jean
jacques de peretti parce que vous êtes
enceinte vous avez frédéric et la
l'engrenage commence parce que votre vie
c'est un engrenage
mais ce qu'il ya d'extraordinaire dans
ma vie c'est que en fait la politique on
n'en faisait pas chez moi mais mes
parents étaient enseignants on n'a
jamais fait de policiers et que
finalement si on regarde ce parcours qui
était absolument est trop c'est vrai que
la politique me poursuit tout le temps
les hommes politiques alors que je les
ai pas cherché
ça c'est drôle c'est le destin c'est le
destin c'est comme lui les rois il y
peut rien
quelque chose qui me frappe c'est que
vous vous avez un point commun camilla
parker bowles a c'est que mon dieu vous
êtes aussi vous fait l'unanimité contre
vous dans un pays alors que finalement
la pauvre il y peut rien elle est aimée
par un homme qui est connue je suis pas
d'accord avec vous je fais pas
l'unanimité contre moi c'est parce qu'on
ne connaît pas je vais vous dire depuis
que j'ai écrit ce livre je suis très
étonné mais je reçois des lettres de
lecteurs et je veux le dire ce soir je
vais en profiter les remercier qui sont
extraordinaires et qui me donne une
force vous pouvez pas imaginer on
voulait vraiment et si moi je continue
encore longtemps on aura le temps après
de parler plus à fond des bois mais je
raconte votre vie parce que quand on
connaît pas aboli son côté mireille
dumas
voilà exactement donc vous mentez à
paris lui fait sciences po il travaille
un peu dans une agence de mannequins
pour faire du booking vous faites et qui
faisait sa wii vous fait des défilés de
lingerie au salon du prêt-à-porter etc
des photos et puis finalement bon vous
passez vos nuits chez castel ou fumer
des pétards enfin les pavés tarn jamais
essayé non non non plus mais j'aurais
peut-être dû rouge a depuis quelques
mois peut-être que j'aurais dû savourer
des donc votre enfant est envoyé dans le
périgord parce que ni le couple explose
koster que jean jacques de peretti il
est absorbé par son boulot
vous vous êtes absorbée par les cris
d'un enfant quand on fait des études
c'est vrai que c'est pas facile et donc
lui à ce moment-là il est pris par le
démon de la politique qui devient chargé
de missions auprès de messmer à matignon
qui à l'époque était l'été prochain
premier ministre
après donc votre fils frédéric avait des
problèmes de santé dont pouvait pas
travailler vous vous retrouvez comme
beaucoup de femmes effectivement ça
parle ça parle aux gens votre histoire
parce que vous retrouvez avec un baume
sur les bras on peut pas travailler
parce qu'il faut s'occuper de lui là
vous rencontrez un dénommé claude
joncour et vous raccrochez un peu à lui
on peut on peut le dire vous lui
demandez de vous épousez je lui demande
pas de m'épouser mais c'est vrai qu'il
est touché un petit peu par par la
situation et puisque puisqu'elle
probablement je lui plais bien et puis
moi j'ai vu le moyen
d'être épaulé et de pouvoir garder mon
fils auprès de moi qui étais toujours
chez ma mère adopte donc de reprendre
mon fils vous marier avec lui
alors c'est un peu compliqué bon parce
que lui c'est pas son fils donc le
week-end il le met devant la porte en
disant il faut pas jean-jacques était
très occupé puisqu'il commencé à faire
ses premiers pas en politique donc c'est
vrai ça prend du temps alors j'encours
claude gens courent donc votre second
mari ils vous présentent un jour alfred
sirven donc c'est lui qui une fois ci je
dis pas qu'il a fait l'entremetteur
enfin il était assez content elle c'est
d'accord pour vous rencontriez sirven et
que vous travaillez avec l'ua veut dire
qu'il sirven alfred sirven dit nous
parce que c'est le seul dans votre
bouquin que j'ai lu deux fois qui
finalement son sort un peu si c'est
vraiment parce que c'est lui qu'ils ont
embrasé en tout la fia certains
électeurs qui m'ont écrit beaucoup me
disant mais pourquoi vous ne connais pas
davantage sur six revers
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que j'ai pas
pensé moi cogner sur six revers
parce que pour moi c'est pas un mauvais
bougre ouais je veux dire il s'occupait
de sa famille s'occuper de ses filles
pour moi c'était déjà un bon point weir
qui s'est quand même sirven masses
urbaines c'est un type qui dit qui a dit
un jour à christine deviers-joncour dis
moi la seule chose que je sais sage
faire c'est donner dé porter des valises
voilà ccc distribuer des concessions
rien faire voilà une autre bien sûr mais
bien faire c'est un type il fait partie
de ce qu'on appelle les affairistes il y
en a beaucoup dans notre république
c'est toujours existé bien sûr même du
temps de la monarchie est là mieux vaut
mieux fermer la négo c'est pour elle
donc numéro deux chez à la traîne avait
rencontré avec votre fiat 500 vous en
étant dans une station et c'est son mari
qui lui a présenté un secteur sur le
corps qui me l'a présenté donc et donc
sirven voit tout de suite la faire
puisque vous rencontrer à ce moment là
c'en est en 1987 vous rencontré roland
dumas vous aider roland dumas a gagné
aux élections
jacques de peretti oui oui je suis de
toute façon déjà au départ de par ma
naissance et mes origines je suis plutôt
socialiste vous savez c'est le pays de
jacquou le croquant le bain donc j'avais
bon la femme un peu surtout la mère
abandonnée
et c'est vrai que quand roland dumas est
venu se présenter en dordogne
c'est vrai que ma mère mon père l'ont
aidé dans ses campagnes
ça me planter dans la circonscription et
c'est vrai que j'ai vu un moyen bon ça
c'est un petit truc
oui donc je le veux je dis je me suis
dit si roland dumas gagnent contre
peretti symptômes à vous avez aidé dumas
il a gagné d'ailleurs et sirven voyant
ça se dit la bonne affaire il se frotte
les mains et il se dit je vais envoyer
christine deviers-joncour au contact de
dumas et alors là effectivement là c'est
le pactole oui on peut se dire quand on
lit ça qui aurait refusé vous appelez ça
un impacteur louis parce que c'est ça la
distribution des caramels non la
distribution des caramels à tout le
monde pas de moi c'est moi j'ai touché
ciel ouvert un auteur une bande dessinée
de l'upci d'huile qui on a en a les noms
et donc sirven on peut dire vous
accroche au pognon quoi parce que c'est
un peu comme une droit quand on en a pas
beaucoup et puis d'un coup on se
retrouve avec beaucoup d'argent c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que c'est vrai
qu'avec cervin on perdre un peu les
pédales
ouais un peu les sondés parce que je me
souviens au début bon moi j'avais jamais
beaucoup d'argent je vivais avec claude
jean court j'avais comme toute femme qui
vit à la maison j'étais une somme au
foyer j'avais une somme à gérer pour
mener la maison ça fait que vous tombez
dans le circuit d'alpha tire là etc
je me souviens quand ils me parlaient de
somme des affaires qui brassent r30 à
gauche je me souviens prendre un peu je
prenais un papier je rajouter les deux
héros et je refaisais 3 3 on comprend
pas ce que je lis paire d'écouteurs
d'anciens prend corps oui oui ça l'est
plus il était en euros vous allez avoir
du mal à nous mais on a peine à
comprendre l'état profite donc on peut
dire à ce moment là vous êtes engagé
chez elf alors xavier onze mille francs
de salaires payés en france
officiellement 40 milles qui était payée
par elf aquitaine internationales à
genève
et on peut dire un peu vous faire vous
le dites dans votre bouquin vous avez un
peu vendu votre âme au diable ce moment
là quoi oui mais je le savais pas que je
vais emmener mon âme au diable
si aujourd'hui communiqué les faits mais
je faisais un travail mieux je faisais
mon travail et j'avais l'impression de
bien le faire je dis aujourd'hui on a
noirci même ce travail que je faisais
dans le noir
on dit mais elle a manipulé un ministre
l'attendait quand j'essayais de ne pas
manipuler mais quand j'essayais de
convaincre le ministre de signer des
contrats importants pour elf aquitaine
ont pas d d assigner des contraintes
pourtant en faisant descendre le
président de la république à tel endroit
où on négocie en rassemblant c'était bon
pour la france l'ue en période de
chômage
il me le disait chez elle qu'il me dit
faut y aller c'est des contrats je tiens
mes avocats me disais vous allez vous
auriez dû être décoré plutôt admise à
fleury mérogis mais je crois que c'est
vrai géant pourquoi on remercie mon
travail aujourd'hui pour enfoncer roland
dumas ce qu'il faut dire aussi qu'il
peut dire si christine effectivement
c'est que elle sape a été créée par
roland dumas ni par personne c'est degré
par de gaulle en 58 attendait que les
affaires elf aquitaine quand on dit
aujourd'hui dans le journaux elf
l'affairé elf aquitaine de pointe
christine deviers-joncour attendait mais
moi je moi je ne peux plus là dans l
affaire elf aquitaine a démarré en 1958
à l'arrivée du général de gaulle
elle a été elle a été créée par l'état
pour l'état en fait c'est une annexe du
pouvoir politique se sert de caisse
noire à l'étape bien plus en jambes
depuis toujours la ferraille qu'il faut
commencer à 1958 mais il faut pas il
faut pas la faire démarrer christine
deviers-joncour attendait
on continue d'histoire mais c'est bien
de le préciser donc là effectivement
vous avez un train de vie l'appartement
une lille
placido domingo qui vient chanter
pavarotti qui vinrent c'était bien que
domingo c'est déjà pas mal
un très beau pialat reçoit c'était
courant est donc là c'est effectivement
vous vous êtes payés par elf pour
organiser les relations publiques de elf
donc effectivement poussé dumas à
certains à signer certains contrats ou à
s'intéresser à certaines à certaines
affaires d'ailleurs vous faites ça très
gentiment sûr que vous dites dans votre
bouquin vous laisser les hommes
parlaient et vous vous êtes un petit peu
comme ça avec les femmes en cuisine vous
attendez que l'édile se fasse quoi donc
vraiment au service de cette affaire oui
je suis au service mais on ne l'a pas
caché au début j'étais là pour les aider
j'employais j'étais là aussi pour
organiser des dîners dans l'appartement
que elf mais avait mis à madisson robert
estienne au début c'est vrai que ce que
je faisais c'était pas je veux dire
c'est normal et entremetteuse de la
république
à l'heure où nous autres faits quand on
nous mettait un contrôle des changes et
un carnet des changes inquiet oui un
carnet de change pour traverser les
frontières
ça vous choque et pas d'avoir un compte
en suisse vous savez monsieur on vous
avez un patron chez alif rentrer chez
elle
moi je sais même pas ce que c'était des
cantons de suisse à l'époque on vous
propose un salaire payé deux ans mille
fois en france et on vous dit bon c'est
pas assez parce que tu travailles
beaucoup dans combattants du verset 1 en
suisse ah bon vous le refusez à la
télévision devant les caméras oui
[Applaudissements]
donc vous raconter d'ailleurs raconté ça
dans le quartier de val d'illiez du
parisien tu voulais raconter cette
semaine là alors il ya des images
absolument extraordinaire c'est sirven
qui fait enfin alfred sirven qui fait sa
tournée
alors il est une voiture et puis dans le
coffre de voiture il ya une couverture
puis sous la couverture et des billets
les billets de 500 et des liasses de
billets de 500 et il distribue quoi il
dit c'est comme le métier sauf qu'au
lieu de livrer du lait il livre des
billets de 500 et alors vous ne dites
pas évidemment aujourd'hui vous n'avez
citer personne vous dit qu'il ya deux
anciens ministres il ya un premier
ministre de gauche donc il comme on est
là depuis son l'a toutefois pas plus je
le dis dans mon livre alfred cervin
donnez donnez toujours des trams mais ne
donnait jamais des détails trop prudent
il avait des tiroirs ils avaient des
codes des choses comme ça donc c'est un
peu les choses que je suis pas
complètement idiote je veux dire j'ai
besoin de tout le monde a entendu des
choses je voyais bien qu'il se passait
des choses et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui je je sors un peu de mes
gonds parce que parce que d'hab sujet
sur lequel planche avant il ya quand
même quelques quelques semaines que mon
patron elle fait qu'elle ferait de
servins n'ait pas été recherchée par la
justice
jusqu'à présent je tire on l'a mis en
prison j'ai subi tout ce que j'ai subi
et je cognais très fort donc j'apprends
ça après c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
cet acharnement de toute cette pression
médiatique sans arrêt avec l'affairé le
président de vision cours l'affairé
c'est vrai que que la maintenant j'en
peux plus en plus là maintenant on prend
l'ailé on me fait des scellés sur des
gars de meubles parce que je déménage on
peut dire que l'on met ses les scellés
sur des affaires de mes fils et cadeaux
de mariage non mais attendez je crois
que là c'est vrai maintenant messieurs
les chips et christine c'est clair de
lampistes comme on dit surtout vous avez
quand même il ya quand même eu dans
cette affaire quatre milliards de francs
distribués à 300 personnes qui ont
touché 4 milliards de fonds alors on
sait a paru dans la presse c'est pas
nous qui le dévoile ce soir
donc je veux dire ça il faut qu'on en
parle il faut que la justice fasse son
travail il ya eu 44 6 personnes qui ont
touché à l'heureux vraiment des salaires
fictifs dans mon dossier qui sont tombés
la presse en a parlé je ne dévoile pas
le secret de l'instruction
donc cela on n'en parle plus je dire
cela ils n'ont pas été mis en examen ils
n'ont pas été mis en détention pour usa
je veux dire mon ça suffit
je suis une femme alors il faut que je
prenne je vais pas je vais pas pleurer
sur mail avril mais c'est normal
bien entendu donc parallèlement à ce
travail donc de relations publiques pour
elle vous tombez enfin je sais pas si
vous tombez amoureux c'est pas moi d'en
parler mais jean-yves in love story etc
roland dumas qui est un peu votre
pygmalion mais ça on comprend très bien
c'est un type formidable très cultivé
qui aime la vie qui ait donné une
instruction mais c'est vrai oui bah vous
avez restauré les deux sens les deux
sens du terme absolu dans les descentes
oui vous avez bien sûr je m'en serais
passé absolument donc ils quittent quand
même pas sa femme pour vous mais vous
connaissez beaucoup de politiques qui
titre d'homme tout court c'est vrai que
j'avais qu'on sache enfin c'était quand
même difficile parce que j'avais jamais
connu ces milieux là j'avais 40 ans
j'avais bon les deux perles qui avait
déjà vais mais des filles de travail
comme ça non mais j'en avais le vase
japonais mais aujourd'hui je me dirais
mais tu as été une folle saab était
gosse et kitty manger aux enfants toutes
les affaires le cigare c'est pas vous
non il ya eu il ya eu il ya eu
il ya des grains des moments d'ambiguïté
dans votre relation dans votre relation
avec jumaa il y avait des moments
d'ambiguïté parce que c'est vrai que bon
j'étais sur mon amoureux l'un de l'autre
en forme plus des photos dans match
qu'on a vue ou qui prouve cette relation
qui parlent d'elles-mêmes absolument
vous êtes bien d'ailleurs tous les deux
sous ça fait aussi agréable surtout de
les voir sur le sable oui et là et vous
et vous vous vous demandez aux vêtements
lui me dit il vous dit temps en temps
est ce que vous êtes là pour moi ou pour
elf aquitaine cire que c'est quand même
une relation ambiguë en même temps parce
que lui il sait bien que vous avez vous
saviez que c'était c'est un travail
quand même c'était c'est vrai que je
suis quand même pas moi il m'a peut-être
qu'il aurait mieux valu peut-être que ça
ne devrait pas amener là où ça ne c'est
plus facile en sachant et tout le monde
savait que j'étais que j'étais la mairie
de roland dumas et c'est vrai que tout
était mélangé le travail un moment donné
tous ces croisés et c'est vrai que
roland dumas et est un homme qui comme
beaucoup d'hommes
il faut quand une femme est amoureuse
selon elle s'accroche elle en veut
davantage et c'est le genre d'homme il
faut surtout pas vous il faut surtout
donc c'est vrai que moi j'avais une
chance extraordinaire et je travaille
est de plus en plus pour elf aquitaine
quand elle me disait faut aller le voir
merci mon dieu je pouvais aller le voir
ça c'est extraordinaire
donc c'est ça ma je les payais très
shirts à une question pas possible ils
gênent encore une fois en tant que femme
je comparais de cette valeur c'est que
vous dites enfin j'imagine que vous
l'aimiez ce que vous le dis très
clairement ça mais c'est en même temps
c'était faire pression de lui faire
faire des choses c'est toute cette
pression c'est en même temps un peu de
la manipulation aussi comment dit on un
vivier dans votre scène et pas de la
boucherie hallal ou l'intégrité et puis
parce que j'ai séverine le lien sommes
dit les choses et c'est vrai la
maîtresse des cellules quand j'allais le
voir et que probablement peut-être il en
avait assez de me venir me voir en tant
que elf aquitaine
peut-être qu'il avait envie de deux que
je vienne le voir en tant que christine
henry viii vraiment léger arrivé en tant
qu elle s'est souvent et bardé sont
félicités tout parce que je peux qui
fait la différence entre le passé et le
présent c'est contre c'est que les
hommes sont devenus vachement plus lâche
beaucoup plus là mais avant les rois il
afficher leurs maîtresses et assumer
leur bâtard et aujourd'hui il couche
avec
en dehors du mariage alors ici assumer
stéphane piscine est l'exemple même des
rangs dit toujours dans l' affaire elf
dans la sphère elle est toujours dans la
sphère est le seul bonhomme c'est que si
vous aviez on m'a dit ça récemment mais
c'est vrai mais qui paraît qu'il y avait
un homme d'horace aquitaine c'était moi
c'est bien de choses sur lesquelles on
s'est focalisé rien selon lesquelles la
presse s'est focalisée il ya
effectivement vous est aussi l'histoire
des chaussures oui la fameuse paire de
chaussures à onze mille francs oui c'est
vrai que c'est impressionnant les gens
une paire de chaussures à onze mille
francs marché avec un smic à chaque pied
c'est énorme
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais j'ai
encore ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'on en
tiendrait à une infirmité c'est vrai que
ce sont des chaussures cher mais c'est
vrai que cela va de la simple
coquetterie
non mais là c'est vrai que j'étais je me
dis pas ça du tout parce que tout le
monde mais c'est vrai que roland dumas a
mais j'ai peut-être qu'il n'aimerait pas
que je dis ça c'est vrai qu'il a un
problème et il a fait une chute de ski à
30 ans il n'a pas voulu faire opérer et
là un tibia qui s'est soudée comme ça
leur manque 5 cm et au fil des années sa
et claudie comme talleyrand voilà et ils
souffrent et moi je me souviens qu'à
l'époque ça les rend la comparaison
c'est juste pour ça non mais j'ai plein
de comparaison des affaires étrangères
tout l'itinéraire une paire de
chaussures parce qu'elle voulait lui
faire plaisir parce qu'il y avait des
gens plus combien on pas les faire
plaisir je lui ai dit il faut que vous
alliez vous faire faire des chaussures
alors en bas de chez moi il y faisait
des chaussures sur mesure et qui a pu
lui mettre le faire une touche pas une
forme on prend par exemple et lui faire
exactement le ce qui manquait pour qui
et qui ne souffre plus voilà et l'aï
l'avs commander ses chaussures
et le jour où il a fallu aller les
chercher en partie partait en voyage
j'accompagnais le voyage officiel les
socrates et le secrétariat map and
hurlus ministres ont dit ses chaussures
il avait des stations debout à faire et
il est venu il veut je passais c'était
en bas mais voilà oui mais il a dû
depuis quand on part du président
conseil du conseil constitutionnel ont
dit roland dumas et ses pairs rien
rappelé
on continue alors donc après je vais
vite affaire des frégates parce que ça
on n'est pas là pour raconter la sphère
des frégates vendues à taïwan
vous touchez finalement bon et qui est
ce qu'elles ont été vendus grâce à vous
pas grâce à vous on va pas faire ça il y
avait à l'époque fectivement par
françoise sagan par exemple à essai
public a influé sur le président
mitterrand à l'époque où on avait trouvé
du pétrole en ouzbékistan
quand on est près des gens puissants
tout le monde essaye de les faire
changer d'avis qui même sur écoute mais
les tirs entendus sont sûrement
dépressionnaire youtube
alors alors encore dans la séance de
décryptage
mais dans quelques années on saura ce
qu'est la mentalité lignol françois 10
bat donc vous toucher 45 millions
vous dites pas besoin de donner un peu
plus vous avez rendu j'ai plus bas vous
dites je les ai rendu et l'appartement
de la rue de lille je suis parti vous
êtes parti
donc voilà aujourd'hui vous vous
retrouvez j'écris un deuxième roman
premièrement les verser une caution de 1
million de familles au revoir sortir
prison comment on va pouvoir sortir de
prison je suis sorti de prison et on m'a
tout ne m'ont donné un mois près de moi
prendre à repousser à trois mois et le
10 septembre il fallait que je verse 1
million sous peine d'y retourner
c'est vrai que j'avais pas les sous la
course contre la montre alors j'ai écrit
ce livre pour cette raison aussi en même
temps pour pour dire qu'ils jettent et
parce que les médias m'avait tellement
massacrés et que c'était pas possible de
survivre à ça j'ai bien fait sur le
livre sur moi reconnaît qu'au départ
j'ai créé ce livre d'abord pour ça mais
après bon c'est vrai que ça m'a servi à
payer la caution
et puis et puis les anciens copains ils
vous aident la manoeuvre est dans le
pétrin ne soit du tout à saluer la lutte
est en prison de gens qu'il a des
lettres anonymes où elle reconnaissait
des détails qui prouvait que c'était ses
amis d'avant qu'il a balancé sur la
nature humaine c'est une leçon
formidable dans des lettres anonymes qui
sont tombés dans mon dossier
j'ai retrouvé des petites phrases et je
savais exactement qui pouvait dire ça
des intimes on avance alors donc vous
allez en prison là effectivement vous
passez directement c'est vrai que c'est
c'est la roche tarpéienne est proche du
capitole parce que c'est vrai que vous
passez de la rue
de ce luxe effectivement à la prison
c'est terrible quoi vous raconter j'ai
pas le faire ici parce qu'on n'est pas
là pour faire
mireille dumas justement mais voilà à
quoi vous raconter c'est vrai que c'est
on va essayer de vous on a essayé de
vous casser pour faire parler pour vous
citiez la maison mes avocats ont dénoncé
oui un chantage médiatique voilà mes
résultats
s'il vous plaît c'est donc excusez-moi
chantage du titien pour me faire parler
je mes avocats m'ont dit que si j'avais
dit des choses sur du mage n'allait pas
prises a entendu et donc vous résister
alors vous vous votre tension tombe à 6
vous perdez 12 kg on met votre fils en
garde à vue vous résister à toutes ces
humiliations de la prison ces gens là
lumière allumée
les gens qui vous regardent par
l'oeilleton enfin j'ai pas voulu
raconter sa veuve cela vous enlevez
votre sourire bien tenu vous êtes mieux
quand vous soyez comme moi des souvenirs
difficiles voilà non mais bon ça c'est
dans le bouquin disons que c'est très
pénible à lire et que ça a dû être
effectivement encore beaucoup plus peiné
la détention toute façon qu'elles soient
provisoires ou pas provisoire c'est vrai
que c'est vrai qu'en sortant je m'étais
dit je vais me battre pour ça pour que
ça se sache
un pays des droits de l'homme et la
france qui se targue d'être le champion
qu'il ya des choses qu'il faut c'est
honteux de laisser mange pas je peux pas
la situation je suis me battre mais
peut-être qu'un jour je le ferai si je
peux si jamais les moyens
puis vous avez peur en prison c'est
rageant il ya deux types qui viennent on
vous dit à deux types qui sont passées
vous dire c'est qu'ils les types qui
sont ces mondiaux repart pour la porte
pour donner la gamelle et et il ya la
madone et puis une co détenus qui sert
et et c'est tout et là je vois deux
messieurs habillé comme vous non sans
lui sans la cravate là mais un peu comme
ça et d'oublier normalement pas oui
et puis ils ont regardé comme ça dans la
cellule
j'ai trouvé ça très étrange et come back
au cellulaire plus l'habitude de la
prison que moi elle a été tout de suite
très très inquiète elle m'a dit ça c'est
dangereux
alors on s'est renseigné effectivement
en user
moi j'ai mené ma petite enquête les la
prison m'a dit que c'était des gens qui
étaient venus faire le devis d'une
cuisine delà des cuisines de fleury et
en fait on appris après que la cuisine
était en fait depuis deux ans c'est pas
qui se profile qu'elles sont vraiment
pour rénover les gars simple c'est vrai
que c'est un peu inquiétant
bah oui non mais toute façon c'est clair
aujourd'hui vous savez beaucoup de
choses ce qui vous plaît beaucoup dans
le choix je le dis dans mon livre alfred
cervin donner des trams une donnée
jamais les détails ce que je dis dans le
parisien aujourd'hui je peux pas en dire
davantage vous dire j'ai pas j'ai pas
allé non j'ai pas assisté moi de toute
façon le fait vous pensez je sais que ça
existe mais d'être médiatisé vous
protège d'une certaine façon je crois
que oui puisque vous poser une question
très bête très pragmatique depuis 16
mois comment vous vivez ça parce que je
le vis très mal mais je le vis je suis
là il faut que je me batte faut que
j'aille jusqu'au bout j'ai mes fils qui
comptent sur moi et sinon je serais pas
ressorti tuilerie mérogis ouais vous et
pensez vous suicider la ba oui plusieurs
fois vous êtes un peu dans la situation
de marilyn monroe
ça fait tellement de choses que les
kennedy l'ont fait supprimer vous savez
ce qui est terrible c'est pas tant la
détention la détention c'est une horreur
mais ce qui est le plus dur je crois
c'est que vous savez on allait en à la
télé on comptines et jeux on avait la
télé dans la cellule c'est de se voir un
beau jour christine deviers-joncour
comme ça en haut un et vous prenez ça de
plein fouet dans huit mètres carrés
assis sur votre paillasson
mais c'est pas vrai en fait c'était mon
image qu'on avait filé en mille morceaux
en reprenait ses morceaux comme un peu
et on mettait et je me reconnaissais pas
je crois que la pression médiatique en
prison m'a fait encore plus de mal que
la justice ou la détention
vous voyez ça cet été les parce que vous
êtes là vous pouvez pas parler pour ne
rien dire que vous cogner contre les
murs qu'on appelle la classe était rien
oui mais en prison oui bien sûr elle est
parlée sur prison c'est une horreur on
pourrait faire puisqu'ils vous énerver
ses comprenait des vieux bouts de films
saisis et page en annexe
pas que je leur vérité avec quoi avec
mes lunettes noires les j'avais
l'impression d'être sais pas quoi c'est
effrayant voyez comment votre avenir là
moi je vois pas d'avenir manger gère au
jour le jour
pour l'instant j'ai pas d'avenir vous
savez j'ai j'ai plus de liberté vous
savez gestion je vais pas ressortir
d'options indicielles je n'ai pas le
plein de gens que je dois pas voir bon
c'est vrai que je suis très encadrée
donc j'ai pas beaucoup de liberté
j'en ai une c'est que le jour où j'en
peux plus j'arrête c'est tout c'est la
seule que j'ai et j'en ai une deuxième
c'est à travers un roman que je suis en
train d'écrire
mais c'est un roman qui est une fiction
je vais pouvoir parler un petit peu de
choses de caractère des gens de ça c'est
une liberté parce que là c'est vrai que
là c'était très signe deviers joncour
oui mais là j'ai envie de parler d'être
un peuple et les hommes
ben justement je vais parler des hommes
donc merci en tous les cas de votre
franchise et bravo pour votre courage
[Applaudissements]
les élus par la lecture d'ebooks
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu